[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم قوات النظام السوري
تواصل قصف ريف ادلب لليوم الثاني على
التوالي وتوقع 14 قتيلا وعشره الجرحى وذلك
بعد يوم من استهداف الكليه الحربيه في حمص
ومقتل عشرات الجنود هذا وقد اتهم الجيش
السوري من وصفها بالتنظيمات الارهابيه
بالوقوف وراءها نحو 80 مصابا فلسطينيا في
مواجهات مع قوت الاحتلال خلال تشيع شهيدين
في بلده حواره حيث هاجم في وقت سابق عشرات
المستوطنين الملثمين والمسلحين منازل ومحل
تجاريه في البلده واطلقوا الرصاص الحي
والحجاره على النوافذ تحت حمايه قوات
الاحتلال اليونسيف ترصد نزوح اكثر من ثلاث
4 مليون طفل على مدى السنوات الخمس
الماضيه بسبب الكوارث الطبيعيه
95% منهم نزحوا بسبب الفيضانات والعواصف
المنظمه قالت ان هؤلاء القاصرين يتعرضون
لمخاطر عده منها احتمال انفصالهم عن
عائلاتهم ووقوعهم ضحايا لشبكات الاتجار
الناشطه الايرانيه نرجس محمدي المسجونه
حاليا في طهران تفوز بجائزه نوبل السلام
لجنه نوبل قالت ان الجائزه كفاءه الناشطه
والصحفيه الايرانيه على معركتها ضد قمع
النساء في ايران وكفاحها من اجل تشجيع
حقوق الانسان والحريه للجميع بحسب قولها
الى
اللقاء